ever guess that you would come up with
that song there's a bad mother [ __ ]
jam this is one of the greatest openings
and the top ten openings in the movie
when said whatever name is tracy lords
takes a good-looking due to the [ __ ]
to do from sons of anarchy to the
[ __ ] he got blown up that dude before
he started telling me though he's not
thats a dude from sun johanna game was
in season 3 or 2 1 [ __ ] blond guy
that used to go to marie ET see over
there ok she takes him to the dance the
vampires [ __ ] they turn into Donald
moga's and the scene get his dick sucked
right after club you see the chick
sucking his dick me sit next to another
one and all of a sudden she comes in
would be
is liz asians jumping up and down
they're all dancing to rave and all of a
sudden the faucet but uh an urban some
where are the [ __ ] pipes of the
ceilings oh [ __ ] it's like a meat plant
upstairs where they kill cows and stuff
but that's what they drain the blood
probably who the [ __ ] else with its
tremendous it's defecting
well infuriates me why cause you went to
all that [ __ ] dragons all you young kids
aren't the dragons and demons and black
vampires and [ __ ] people coming back
with the [ __ ] dead intercession what
I never understood that people sitting
at home every [ __ ] Sunday watching
the show but people coming back to the
dead and everybody wants to be an
apocalypse and people going down to the
shore dressing up like zombo's and
walking around get together go eat your
wife's [ __ ] we you don't believe in
dressing up like a zombie yeah yeah I'd
do it every [ __ ] weekend that's me
that's what i do i want to dress up like
a zombie and walk around like get the
[ __ ] outta all right go watch a whatever
Romero movie get the full effect that's
what daughters are dead and all those
movies how long how long did you dress
up for Halloween until what age like I
did like a unit is like the rain knowing
that [ __ ] you i just put on a hat what
Trick or Treat [ __ ] I swear to god I'm
running tonight sure I wasn't it to
dress up people dressed enough Mike
[ __ ] we call those people in the
weekends they dress with my vikings and
that fares [ __ ] oh they stab each other
rubber swords really yeah you know they
got under that oh yeah yeah I can't when
I quit this career that's something I
have to fight p by every [ __ ] weekend
rubber swords and make him believe I'm
an English boy you're speaking want to
[ __ ] the back seat given been to
comic-con yet oh yeah I go every [ __ ]
here walk around comic-con my gosh
I didn't I went to the gym I need to
push up and you stayed even extra long
time ago now when I have you said our 15
just gonna look good job because i
always kill it when I when we have the
munchies movies did you watch site today
I'm watching a dark night the one with
the heath ledger just something mindless
it's a good movie build a treadmill my
mind goes off and then I I focus too
much on the time with the music laughter
lower you down with the movie I just get
distracted
using how much I'm starting to dislike
my gym just because the people who go
there every day there's at least three
or four people with with scripts on the
elliptical with them and then today this
dude turned it up to a speed that no one
can ever run it it was like he was
trying to run like a superhero but he
was banging
err upstairs would have to notice him
and I did it bugged me he did it for
like 20 minutes I just I've never liked
that kind of trying to get attention now
you know I don't go to the [ __ ] gym
especially at the gym now you know why
keep it simple at the YMCA now you know
and the way I'm saying the Hollywood was
a good gym but they had their [ __ ]
moments to don't get confused great gym
great staff you know they opened up at
five in the [ __ ] morning you're going
at 10 25 mm-hmm you jump in the [ __ ]
heated pool and then you're going to
steam for a little one you want a song
you take a little shits very nice but
every once in a while they'd be an
[ __ ] that would come in naked in late
towels everyone just spread out like
this was his [ __ ] living room and you
had to sit there like you know like
[ __ ] you got a cold in the corner you
like [ __ ] you you know you gotta pick up
your town guy there's other people that
we know it was kind of rude but for the
most part seventy percent of time it was
a great gym I don't want to be a part of
a gym when I gotta dress up and see
chicks
we're in [ __ ] type like their suits
the [ __ ] proportion their socks
around perfect their sneakers then I
kind they go to the women at those gyms
oh because they go to the gym and I fig
on a pair they do 20 minutes and they
leave it is the [ __ ] most pathetic
thing in their life then they go get a
coffee that's like they did this [ __ ]
thing then do [ __ ] they do curls they
look around they walk around it's a
[ __ ] nightmare there's a lot of guys
who died I saw a guy who would do spurts
of 10 seconds on the elliptical get up
he would go wipe I didn't do it and blow
his nose and then he would look out cuz
it overlooks the weight room and then he
would take here to it always I I love
junk food but I would never be with
a hostess doughnuts those powdered
doughnuts and the soda from 7-11 just
eating it at the gym and what was he
doing was elliptical no he was just
sitting down in front of the ellipticals
chillin and this this gym is amazing is
it it's hysterical to watch and then
even even the people who work there
aren't that cool they're cool when
they're taking my money like when I
signed up there now I go in and ask for
a towel and i'm lucky if i even get one
or or get an answer it's a really yeah i
don't know what it is i don't know if
it's cuz i'm chubby something but
they're very they're not very customer
and hit there i mean i think maybe they
just don't like being at the front desk
maybe it's a shitty place that's a
[ __ ] job you took you gotta like you
gotta drink some type of [ __ ] down
you know yeah hi like i said uh years
ago Christy Miller and economic friend
of mine gave me a free year when I was
falling
and I'll tell you what they were very
nice I always had a great time in there
the guys were gay but didn't bother me
at all
hey Jim but it really wasn't right what
24 hour fitness open I I thought about
I guess the pool is open 24 hours go at
night
said caught myself and said I don't like
those type of places i know i'm not
gonna like it even then even if I one
person this is the pod gasps and they're
nice to me they tell the rest of the
staff Hayes on a great podcast or he
goes to the joe rogan spark out it's
still wouldn't I just knew I think I
don't want to see girls dressing up when
I
why the [ __ ] I'm there I see some crazy
[ __ ] people to walk what do they do I
just see crazy [ __ ] people at the Y
like there's a Hindu couple he's got to
be 70 and she's got to be [ __ ] like
65
and they come in and she gets on the
treadmill and she walks and he gets on
the bicycle and he rides a bicycle for
like eight minutes then he go
it's they punches the bag for two months
when he comes the yells at her make that
I was anti [ __ ] go it's very cute
there's people that are trying to lose
weight that kids are all [ __ ] fat
those little fat [ __ ] Mexican kids
and the daughters I see a whole family
than the treadmill and they're you know
the whole families in there it's a
family place right but even when I was
single and I was just dating Terry I
went in a why because I just didn't want
to feel like I don't want to pay on it
Jim we're pretty people going that makes
movies at the bar and coffee it's not a
[ __ ] gym map right I heard that uh
planet fitness I think it has pizza and
donut days of the gym have you heard
about that crazy you know I want a gem
that has a great selection oh yeah I
like the why doesn't have kettlebells I
gotta go out to my car and get the
cattle battles and go on North Hollywood
Park you know but the Wyatt
the treadmill make up the [ __ ] bag
and they got a couple of Olympic bars
and some benches and that's all I need
I'm 50 years old I don't need the
[ __ ] jump off buildings and [ __ ] you
know and I'm happy that you went to 24
hour fitness I'm happy that you continue
to go but you see it for what it is
after a while I just don't believe that
they treat you like that that they yeah
that's real to be cool you have to be
cool or be a producer or that that gym
when you told me that the guy from
Sunday Aniki went there hold in it's got
to have some type of you know if one guy
goes that crispy asking
psalm and him but uh this Hollywood why
do I go to shocks me like I said it just
[ __ ] shots me sometimes I can't
believe I'm in a lot of old people
nobody's hot you know there's very
seldom a chick and I think I've seen
chicks that have gone like the first
week and get dressed up and there's
nothing in there for them but I never
see him in there again
Thanks I mean I'm not complaining when
the girls dressed up they look